Zachary is in Texas hi Zachary welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how are
you better than I deserve what's up so I
got a I got a question for you so I make
about $20,000 a year I'm doing like
digital marketing sales and then I'm
also working a side job just serving at
a restaurant and I have about $25,000 in
debt
21,000 of it which is my car and the
cars only worth 17,000 and I want to
sell it and get out of debt but if I
sell it my dad said he's going to kick
me out of my house because I'm still I'm
20 years old
I'm you know anyway so he's trying he's
gonna kick me out if I sell my car in
because I don't want to listen to his
advice and build credit so later down
the road I can buy a house or a car and
I tried telling him that like you know
I'll pay cash for a car any car that I
buy from here on out and all that stuff
he's just he just I think he's mad that
I don't want to listen to his advice and
I'm just not sure what to do here what
what do you make a year around 20,000 or
so with both my incomes
okay so you have two part-time jobs well
I'm working full-time now and I'm making
1,500 a month but I can make more with
Commission it's just I'm you know still
learning how to sell SEO work and stuff
so yeah okay could you get a roommate
and survive on $20,000 a year I I mean
not right now not anyone that I know of
I don't know how to find a roommate
I know that my cousin and his and his or
her boyfriend want to move in and August
but he said if I sell the car he wants
me off my February I wasn't talking
about him I was talking about you oh
okay this is a toxin what I'm hearing is
a toxic situation okay okay I mean your
dad is trying to toss you out of the
house yeah so that means it's time to
leave regardless of the car discussion
okay way he's acting means it's time for
you to leave yeah so I'm gonna start
making plans to leave and then I'll
worry about then let's worry about the
car
okay it's time for you to get out of
there okay just because I mean smite
threatens you know it's like your boss
walks in every day and threatens to fire
you
yeah you know any like mention either
get a new job you know yeah I mean I
want to I want our relationship to be
good but it's well that's up to him and
that's up to you and if his if your
relationship with someone is dependent
on you completely taking their advice
you're never gonna have a relationship
with someone yeah because no one takes
your advice all the time my freaking
family does not take my advice all the
time okay
and I'm freaking Dave Ramsey okay so I
mean if you just have to have
relationship with people in spite the
fact they don't listen to you and if you
can't have that kind of grace in your
life you're not gonna have anybody in
your life because no one does everything
you say to do I don't even do everything
my wife tells me to do no one does
that's absurd
so the way the only way I can have a
relationship with you is if if you if I
do everything you say to do well sorry
things work out yeah so he's going to
sound like any got some growing up to do
I'm sorry this would bring a lot of pain
to you and I'm joking around about too
much but you do need to make some plans
or in the near future aside from the car
issue to get out of there and then make
your decisions about your car okay and
we're not trying to be mean to your dad
but he's obviously he's obviously giving
you lots of signals this time together
so okay let's get let's get your career
moving get some income coming in and get
on out of there and then you make your
decision what to do with the car oh my
you must stay in bed or you can't live
here
that's so backward